in the meantime that stimulus that went
up for a pretty close vote in the House
of Representatives last night now a lot
of folks are saying it's dead on arrival
in the Senate but it was in all
exclusively along party lines there were
more than a dozen Democrats who voted
against it including Oklahoma Democratic
Congress a woman who was among those to
say no no this is not my cup of tea at
Kendra horn congressman very good to add
you why were you a no vote on his
congressman
good morning glad to be here I was a no
vote because we're in the midst of an
unprecedented health and economic crisis
with Kovan 19 and our communities need
relief but in order to get the support
and and the stimulus where it needs to
go we have to ensure that our packages
are timely targeted and transparent
timely relief requires that bills be
passed through the House the Senate and
be signed into law to get the help and
support to our families our communities
our first responders our businesses and
this didn't have strong bipartisan
support targeted we need to be focused
on the areas that kovat 19 has impacted
and this bill contained a lot of
extraneous provisions and then finally
on transparency we got an 1,800 page
bill on Tuesday and we're asked to vote
on it on Friday in order to respond to
this unprecedented crisis we have to be
able to have open debate and discussion
across the aisle to get to solutions
that work for everybody in our
communities and this just didn't meet
those bars now some opposition was
expected congresswoman not the 14
including yourself of the Democrats who
who didn't vote for this now some were
saying well you're in a Republican area
you've won in a Republican area and
you're feeling the pressure I believe
the other represent is all Republican
we're similarly against this do you feel
that pressure does it put you in an odd
position it's not about pressure to me
it's about good governance it's about
making sure that that the people in my
community and the businesses the health
care workers get the support they need
and in order to do that we've got to get
it across the finish line we can't be
playing partisan games I don't care
which side of the aisle you're
with this pandemic this is not a time
for partisanship it's a time for us to
get to work and get their resources and
support to our state and local
governments or cities that are suffering
our businesses that are trying to keep
open and our families many of whom have
lost their job through no fault of their
own this is about getting things done
and getting it done the right way
because the help is needed and we should
we should all come together to make that
happen you know what what more people
are talking with Congress one about the
way this was voted on whether you're
Democrat a Republican by proxy or
remotely and that that this you know is
it's probably not a good path to follow
number Democratic and Republican
representatives have told me that does
that give you pause well I supported the
change to the rules that allowed proxy
voting or remote hearings because right
now it is more important than ever that
we are able to conduct the full business
of the house and if we have some members
that have underlying health conditions
and need to participate remotely I think
there are safeguards in place but I do
believe that we have to be fully in
session and fully engaged because the
needs of our communities are too great
right now and we have other work to do
I'm on the Armed Services Committee we
have to finish the Defense Authorization
but we have to get appropriations done
and then we have to make sure that the
that the programs we pass are actually
working as they're intended so all of
these things have to happen and whether
it's in person and I'm here I'm happy to
be here to do the work because the
communities need it those safeguards are
in place it's just for the emergency but
we can't stop conducting all of our
constitutional responsibilities
Congressman Kendra horn thank you very
much for taking the time we do it thank
you very much